no one is going to catch the chiefs in
the end and the afc
west they have clinched that division
shocker
it almost was a shocker though of an
outcome
when the chiefs returned to hard rock
stadium
patrick holmes tweeting i have a
love-hate relationship with
hard rock stadium here is mahomes after
the game explaining
his love and his hate of hard rock
stadium
i love part i mean we've won the super
bowl super bowl here and uh we
we've just clinched afc west and so it
seems like every time we leave this
stadium where we have a hat
of some type of thing we've accomplished
but in the hate part i feel like i have
half my interceptions it seems like at
this stadium
i i talked to him after the game and we
we really got into
the similarities between
you know the whole idea of going back to
miami they stayed in the same hotel he
stayed in the same room it just brought
back a lot of those feelings at a time
when
you know maybe it's useful to rekindle
that that
that fire that spirit that carried you
to a super bowl championship because
you're getting ready to embark on that
run again and
you know he said it was strange to be
back in the stadium and look around and
take it all in
uh and yes he had three interceptions
and it could have gone the other way
this is just another example of how good
the chiefs fundamentally are
they will take the best shot you have
they will suffer through all sorts of
crazy adversities
including a 30-yard sack at one point
that
as mahomes told me after the game he
flipped the field on himself
in that one but they just they they just
keep going they just keep you know
they're down 10 nothing it's no big deal
and you we all have this sense
of it's coming it's coming it's coming
and from 10-00 to 33-27 and it wasn't
even as close as 33-27
no i mean you know come on come on
come on in the year of 2020
there's no great great defenses in the
nfl
a lot of good ones but i don't know if
there's that great defense we've seen in
other years i i don't know
how can you pick against this crew and
this guy how can you pick against
him i just don't see it it's
unbelievable i've never seen anything
like it
the way they make plays the way he can
flounder
and not look good for a little bit and
just not be flustered at all and oh hey
oh
yeah it was a rough start i threw for
393 and still had some of the best
throws in the nfl today whoa
okay hey don't worry we lit the
afterburners and a bunch of our guys
they're just flying all around the field
no big deal we'll score 28 like that
i've never seen anything like it and
it's scary because they're 12-1
they haven't played a complete football
game the whole year and
if they even just come close they're
going to beat teams 48 to 12
48 to 14. it could have been that
yesterday even down 10 nothing
i mean they drive down the field they're
up 30 to 10 mccole hardman fumbles
inside the 10-yard line
they drive down the field it's 30 to 10
and xavien howard goes up and makes the
one
hand interception great interception but
my home's under thrown by like
nine yards should have been touchdown so
it just i'm amazed by them sorry i'm
waxing poetically about them but
you know it's just amazing what we're
seeing well one of the things that i was
most
interested in finding out when talking
to the homes after the game and i hadn't
talked to him after a game since that
that snow globe game i remember in
kansas city last year when you get the
broncos
and we all started to say you know what
maybe we should be paying more attention
to this team instead of the 49ers and
the ravens and the other teams that were
the great teams last year because the
chiefs really weren't
until we got to the end of the season i
asked him
what's your process you so rarely have
interceptions what's your process
for getting past an interception when it
happens and he said
i'm not going to change my mentality i'm
going to continue to fire i'm going to
continue to shoot the ball downstairs
and let my guy try to make plays
whenever you start being timid after you
throw an interception
that's how you lose games and that's
yeah he he doesn't
go into a shell he doesn't get careful
he doesn't look for high
percentage completions he just keeps
doing what it is that he does and he
loses no faith in the fact that he made
a mistake and he accepts the fact that
he may make him
another but he knows on balance it's all
going to work out and he's not going to
ever change the way he is and that's the
right way to approach it when you have
that kind of a skill set
it's it's amazing it's just we've never
really seen a guy who can handle it so
well
at such a young age and has never really
been flustered
i mean never i've never seen panic on
the guy's face or anything in my life
other than his first game up in
foxborough on nbc a sunday night
football game i remember him in the
huddle
and the little sky cam zoomed in on him
i remember him looking up
and i felt like that was the first time
ever i've ever seen him where he was
aware like oh man
i'm in new england and i'm playing tom
brady and of course if you remember you
got off to like a slow start in that
football game
other than that i've never seen them
blink ever even down 20
20 to 10 last year against the 49ers you
know i thought oh it's not looking good
but he wasn't like stressed or blinking
about it
you know his ability to just kind of
wipe the slate
clean and still
after those mistakes like make mistakes
and then come back and and actually be
more aggressive
that's where most quarterbacks would
really falter
oh i've made a few mistakes and now it
compounds itself
and now you start to leave plays on the
field because you don't want to make a
mistake or
man maybe i'm not seeing the field
clearly let me check it down let me
throw the easy completion
and then you get up on a few drives and
you look and you go man we got two field
goals and i've missed like two or three
big plays maybe for touchdowns
because i'm still scared about the damn
interceptions i threw earlier
he just never does that he just fires
and
there that that's where i just he's
amazing in the clutch or at any moment
it just doesn't really matter but it
speaks to their football team they don't
really blink either
and that's because of him and they're
you know he's their fearless leader but
uh it's special that he has that little
characteristic about him
and you know that attitude extends
beyond any given game either i asked him
at one point how important the number
one seed is for the chiefs and his
attitude is
we don't care yeah like tell us when we
have to play
and we'll go play if we get a week off
we get a week off if we don't
we don't and there's a certain
pragmatism to it that there's only so
much they can control
if they end up losing out on a
tiebreaker to the steelers so be it
although
as of last night with the steelers
losing they don't have to worry about a
tiebreaker they have a one-game lead now
in the chase for the number one seed
so the chiefs are looking good in that
regard and they likely will get
that week off i don't want to say likely
they quite possibly i don't know what
the specific probability is steve
kornacki had it last night but i'd say
it's looking good
and it's up to 95 95 to be the one seed
wow 95 to be the one seed so i think
they're in pretty good shape and
and look when you reflect on what
happened last year and how they had to
pull the inside straight three games in
a row i don't think you
want to throw another one on to that
where you fall behind
and you have to keep finding a way to
come back i don't think you want to risk
that one more time if you don't have to
so take the one seed chiefs
and run with it take the week off
because they're eventually going to have
a couple of pretty good football teams
rolling into town
whether it's the titans whether it's the
bills whether it's the colts whether
it's the browns whether it's the
steelers yeah or maybe even the dolphins
there's plenty of good teams out there
and uh they're gonna have to beat two of
them to get back to the super
yeah that's right that's why you want
the buy though just for the reasons you
just said just so you don't have to play
three of them
because it's just it's it's wrong with
the dice the afc is damn good
i mean as we've seen the as we have seen
this year
you know the team that they've had the
most problems with is not even in the
playoffs
you know we've seen the colts the colts
beat them two years ago
in kansas city with a healthy patrick
mahomes so
uh the asc is deep and talented and yeah
you don't want to roll that dice
to me i mean yeah i think you me
everybody in the football universe yeah
that's right he doesn't care we don't
expect them to care either i
we know they can beat and play with
anybody on any field but you just want
to take that little percentage chance
away of
okay let's not have to play that extra
game against that one team who's
pretty damn good and oh no if this was
the day we made a few mistakes sure
didn't capitalize now it comes back to
bite us in the butt and the season's
over
uh that that to me is the beauty of it
but man how can you pick against them
and
i really what's the closest thing just
in and you're just off the top of your
head like what's the closest thing in
your lifetime
you've seen to the chiefs and just the
the way they play
and just how quickly you can all turn
around
well i i look the closest the closest
i've seen by way of dominance to the
chiefs offensively is the 49ers of the
late 80s right never had
to really turn it around they just came
out and kicked your butt and fired a
wire yeah
right i i can't think of a team that
that
could always find the switch and flip it
no matter whether they're down 10 24 as
we saw last year against the texans
right
it really is amazing and you you you
develop
a skill at coming back and what it does
and one thing mahomes told me is we
don't point fingers we don't get
down in the mouth they don't need to
because they know they can do it they
know they can come back
and it has a mental impact on your
opponent
yeah they feel it on the other sideline
these things that become trends in the
nfl
whether it's and i remember heinz ward
used to say that you know with tony romo
when when when he was in that period of
of his career and he eventually reversed
it where you can count on him to make a
big mistake late in the game
you sense it you sense here it comes and
i think that anybody who's playing the
chiefs i
i bet there were plenty of guys on the
miami sideline yesterday chris when it
was ten nothing
who were over there thinking oh crap
yeah here it goes here it goes it's
what's happening right in front of us i
mean we've never seen this in person but
this is amazing even though
we shouldn't be enjoying it uh because
miami did do a lot of good things
they did you know or you know early on i
i
i think that andy reid and kansas city
were very careful
with miami because they were feeling
them out because they had respect for
the scheme the players everything out
like that
you know tua even though it wasn't
beautiful
you know and i still think they're
managing him to a degree hey
gritty made some big plays when he
needed to
just got to take away a few of those
dead moments you know where they go up
10 nothing and then it's just nothing
for a long long period of time
before they kind of got a jump started
once again but
you know miami hey whether they make the
playoffs or not because
they got a tough stretch and there's no
guarantee they will be a pain in the
butt to play because you're not going to
want to see brian flores and that
defense come into town
they can match up with just about
anybody except for maybe this team in
red with one and a five
at quarterback we've got some time
carved out later in the show to talk
about the conversations i had after
yesterday's games remind me if i forget
to explain what patrick mahomes had to
say about tour because it was
encouraging
if you're a dolphins fan hi i'm mike
tarico and thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports